>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW IS
ARI FLEISHER, FORMER WHITE
HOUSE SECRETARY, AUTHOR OF
"SUPPRESSION, DECEPTION, SNOB
BRIE AND BIAS," WHY THE PRESS
GETS SO MUCH WRONG.
ALONG WITH SEAN DUFFEY, FORMER
WISCONSIN CONGRESSMAN.
ALL ARE FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTORS.
MR. DUFFEY, WANT TO START WITH
YOU.
DEMOCRATS, REPUBLICANS LOOKING
AT THIS WHOLE PLAN FOR THIS
PLANT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT COMES
IN AND JUST SAYS, NO, THIS
ISN'T WORKING.
YOUR REACTION TO THIS?
>> THIS IS NOT A RICH AREA.
THIS PERIOD OF WISCONSIN WAS
IN MY OLD DISTRICT IN AN AREA
FOR 40 OR 50 YEARS NORTHERN
WISCONSIN WAS ALL BLUE.
NORTHERN MINNESOTA WAS ALL
BLUE.
ALL DEMOCRATS.
IT'S NOW HARD-CORE RED BECAUSE
OF CRAZY POLICIES LIKE THIS
THAT COME FROM DEMOCRATS.
LAURA, IT GETS COLD IN
NORTHERN WISCONSIN.
IT GETS TO BE 30-BELOW.
WE NEED RELIABLE AND CHEAP
ENERGY TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
HEAT OUR HOMES.
WHAT'S OUTRAGEOUS ABOUT WHAT
THE EPA IS DOING IS THE FACT
THAT THIS POWER PLANT IS GOING
TO HELP MOTH BALL COAL-BURNING
POWER PLANTS FOR THE NATURAL
GAS-BURNING POWER PLANT WHICH
MEANS THERE'LL BE LESS CO2 IN
THE AT ATMOSPHERE.
THE LIBERALS ARE FIGHTING TO
MOTH BALL IT.
MOTH BALL THIS PLAN.
THIS IS THE PROBLEM IN
GOVERNMENT.
YOU CAN ELECT DONALD TRUMP,
GEORGE BUSH OR JASON CHAFE
FITZ BUT UNLESS YOU GET RID OF
THE FEDERAL UNIONS, THE DEEP
STATES, IN THE EPA, YOU COULD
NEVER CHANGE POLICY.
DONALD TRUMP COULDN'T GET RID
OF THE RADICALS IN THE EPA.
DO WHAT SCOTT WALKER DID IN
WISCONSIN, ERADICATE THE
UNION, FIRE ALL OF THESE
40-YEAR EMPLOYEES AT THE EPA
AND BRING IN FRESH BLOOD, AND
YOU WON'T HAVE THESE PROBLEMS.
AS LONG AS YOU KEEP THESE
RADICALS EMPLOYED, YOU COULD
NEVER CHANGE COURSE.
LISTEN, THEY'LL TAKE OUT
EXISTING NUCLEAR PLANTS, COAL
PLANTS, GAS PLANTS, THEY'LL
TAKE OUT WELLS.
THEY WANT TO GET RID OF
EVERYTHING SO WE'RE ALL
RELIANT ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WE CAN'T AFFORD FOOD, GAS,
OIL, AND SO WOE TO THE
GOVERNMENT TO SUBSIDIZE THE
COSTS FOR US WHICH MEANS WE'RE
NOT INDEPENDENT AND FREE.
WE RELY ON THEM.
IT'S INSANE.
>> Laura: ARI, THEY HAD
JUMPED THROUGH ALL OF THESE
HOOPS FOR THIS.
I'M USING THIS JUST AN EXAMPLE
OF WHAT THEY'RE CAPABLE OF.
THIS WOULD HAVE REDUCED STRAIN
TO THE GRID.
THIS WOULD HAVE REDUCED CARBON
DIOXIDE EMISSIONS THE WAY THE
PLANT IS SET UP.
IT'S BRILLIANT.
I WAS IN MINNESOTA FOR EIGHT
DAYS.
I READ THE WHOLE THING.
IT'S STUNNING.
THEN THE ACTIVISTS COME IN AND
THEY ROLL RIGHT THROUGH.
IF THE REPUBLICAN GETS
ELECTED, TO SEAN'S POINT,
THERE HAS TO BE A FULL REFORM
OF THE CIVIL SERVICE.
THIS IS CRAZINESS!
>> YEAH, I DON'T WANT TO
OBJECT TO THAT AT ALL ON THE
CIVIL SERVICE.
PEOPLE THOUGHT DONALD TRUMP,
OH MY GOD.
SCHEDULE F THE WAY YOU DO
THIS.
AND PEOPLE ARE HAVING VAPORS.
IT'S ACTUALLY TRUE.
IT IS MEANINGFUL CIVIL SERVICE
REFORM IF YOU GET OUT THE
PARTISANS BUT A COUPLE POINTS
HERE, LAURA.
LET'S START WITH JOE BIDEN'S
TAPE YOU JUST ROLLED.
ONE, HE HAS A HARD TIME
PUTTING IN ONE SENTENCE NEXT
TO ANOTHER SENTENCE.
I MEAN, THE MAN IS GETS WORSE.
TWO, HE SAID THAT ENERGY
PRICES ARE GOING TO GO DOWN?
AS A RESULT OF THIS, ENERGY
PRICES ARE GOING TO GO UP
BECAUSE WE'RE DRIVING FOSSIL
FUELS WHICH ARE THE CHEAPER
FUELS OUT OF BUSINESS --
THAT'S IF THE DEMOCRATS GET
THEIR WAY -- THROUGH MASSIVE
SUBSIDIES THROUGH CORPORATIONS
THAT MAKE GREEN ENERGY.
THAT ALWAYS DRIVES THE PRICE
UP.
AND THEN FINAL POINT, NONE OF
THIS IS GOING TO WORK.
IF YOU THINK THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN SPEND MONEY AND
MAKE US GREEN OR FIX OUR
ENERGY ISSUES, IT IS TOTALLY
THE WRONG APPROACH FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO TAKE.
BUT THERE'S A FINAL POINT
HERE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE PARTY UNITY.
THAT'S WHY THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
PASS THIS.
SENATOR KRYSTEN SINEMA OF
ARIZONA IS ON BOARD.
THAT'S A LESSON TO
REPUBLICANS.
PARTY UNITY IS IMPORTANT.
THE DEMOCRATS FIGURED OUT, AT
LEAST HERE, HOW TO STOP
ARGUING AND GET SOMETHING
DONE.
REPUBLICANS COULD LEARN THAT
LESSON, TOO.
>> Laura: I'LL SAY.
JASON, DESPITE EVERYTHING
WE'VE LAID OUT HERE, WONDER
BOY PETE BUTTIGIEG, THEY THINK
HE'S A HOPEFUL FOR 2024, HE
STILL IS BLAMING EVERYONE BUT
THE ADMINISTRATION.
CHECK IT OUT.
>> WE CONTINUE TO SEE SHOCK
WAVES DISRUPTING EVERY PART OF
OUR ECONOMY FROM THE PANDEMIC
AND FROM THE OTHER GEO
POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC THINGS
THAT ARE TAKING PLACE.
WE'RE JUST KEEPING OUR HEADS
DOWN AND DOING THE WORK.
IN MY DEPARTMENT, THAT MAKES
IT EASIER TO AFFORD E.D.'S AND
OTHER THINGS TO PROTECT
AMERICANS FROM THE EFFECTS OF
THE UPS AND DOWNS FROM THE OIL
MARKET.
>> Laura: JASON, THIS IS
PURPOSEFUL SABOTAGE.
>> YEAH, HE WAS KEEPING HIS
HEAD DOWN TAKING A NAP WHILE
OFFICE MATERNITY LEAVE.
THAT'S WHERE HE WAS.
THIS ISN'T PUTIN'S FAULT.
THIS WAS ABSOLUTELY
SELF-INFLICTED PAIN TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE UNIFIED AS
ARI SAID AND SAID WE'RE GOING
TO GET RID OF FOSSIL FUELS.
EVERY BIT OF ENERGY IS GOING
TO INCREASE.
EVEN IF IT'S GOING TO BE
CLEANER FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
LIKE THIS PLANT IN WISCONSIN
WHICH WAS GOING TO SAVE I
THINK REDUCE THE EMISSIONS BY
A MILLION TONS OVER A
SIGNIFICANT PERIOD OF TIME.
THEY DON'T WANT NUCLEAR.
THEY DON'T WANT ANYTHING.
I'M ALL-OF-THE-ABOVE ENERGY
GUY.
THAT'S THE WAY TO DO THIS, BUT
THIS ADMINISTRATION, THEY'RE
GOING TO DO EXACTLY WHAT THEY
SAID.
GET RID OF EVERY BIT OF
PETROLEUM.
EVERYONE IS GOING TO PAY THE